my I say scared of butterflies don't
stop hey what are we doing today
Oh like we're gonna do yesterday
Archer you can't see me that spooky
these squares are so beautiful feel like
The Sound of Music
I don't know what this is where's the
liquor American food but it's good but
very fat we made it to the park I want
to touch so people use this in their bed
sheets apparently oh oh oh Sh oops
oh my god that's so pretty I've spotted
the enemy so now we're at a graveyard
I I don't know why that's pretty epic
can we go inside let's do it all right
what did we get way too big ooh pretty
very nice Sweden
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait oh my god we have to go
it's fun
guess where we're going right now
quiet fun everyone this is the best
thing I have ever seen Oh
for you what how old are these that's
awesome
okay that's cool what is it they're
massaging each other that's oh that's me
mari oh my god you look at that
this is Planet fun guys I'm having fun
oh my god it's Kingdom Hearts I found
the best one yeah
Planet fun is right here thumbnail
okay bunny is killing it and duck hunt
like my favorite game really yeah I just
do this really many hours wait ever
Levine the manga hey fantastic bubble
action going on right now he's doing
drugs it looks like we got some Mario
drugs going on
haha I can't film this this is not being
filmed Rex bubble action okay look
fantastic
hey keep blowing this is fantastic
yeah okay we stopped outside of college
and we haven't moved there you go how's
it going
error 404 clever sign not found please
contact in so funny I forgot to laugh
I found this it's the guy he worked on
silent hill's
it's really freaky I'm really happy I
found ya okay
and yes 640 34 we're going on a ghost
tour after this we're back at the hotel
I'm doing some social media stuff for
the book and I it's coming out soon and
I'm really nervous I don't know how
people want to react to it
you've given me good feedback but I
never like the general public has not
given me their opinion about the book so
I'm nervous how people are gonna see it
is that ours
oh that's not ours okay well we're going
in dialogue but we're doing this one
it's confusing
it's hurting time maybe it's hurting
time my sleigh is ready to hurt us this
is our hearts one hearse to hers which
hers is our hearse
Yara I'm just like saying hurt her purse
purse how many is too many vlog is going
on right it's so awkward
whatever she said we're doing we're in
the hearse is healthier they come out
Renee we're trying to summon your spirit
and you know what she does she haunts
that room so that's why our mannequin
guest is there but that's the old 1790
y'all get anything in your photos so we
got a shot I'm getting out hitting
anything nobody you guys finding any
goes we survived the hearse barely time
for pizza it's so good oh all right
we're heading back home
uh-huh - those how this will be at the
end of this day good day good pizza kind
of shitty tour but they had alcohol so
it was okay and I'll see your model day
for we're gonna get a lunch
Mattson where are we going shopping
I love shopping this is the brain of
Nobel Peace Prize winner this will make
me smarter I remember this one
I got a low the camera got all away I
made it today we didn't do much I mean
we just walked around very exciting vlog
probably I'm just gonna keep doing
nothing and you're doing the same as I'm
doing right now have fun
yes we are about to have a life-changing
experience II all it's the same the sale
this part it's not polluted it's four
G's well we had to quit our dinner early
it was Bunny's fault
doing the ghost tour
I don't believe it we found a real ghost
they will they will attest and they'll
go for your jugular we finished a ghost
or did you like it
she loved it you like my earring okay
I'm gonna end today's vlog here today
here it looked like I have a weird
mustache okay I'll see you tomorrow all
right we are heading back home I'm about
to teleport because that's just what I
do
oh thank you
we just got drug dealer kitchen chicken
[ __ ] did you see that look at that line
that was the line for the secret chicken
illegal secret fund a chicken baby
secret chicken baby oh it's even better
one is not allowed I just had to show
the chicken part but I'm gonna back to
teleporting
I
oh okay we're finally home I hope that
was a decent belong at least probably
not the most exciting I'm going to get
the pugs now there with Martha's brother
whose dog sitting hey hey hey how you
doing buddy I missed your pouch
I will now steal your finger so you will
never leave me again
I'm sure happy part sir you are back
he's been long hard and not the good
kind of will it's 10:00 in the morning I
don't know it's like I'm too tired to do
anything great great way to end the vlog
don't do anything today because that way
I will feel productive stay awesome rose
just felt like it was time to get a real
tattoo
on my foot whoo that is really cool I'm
not a Swedish anymore we're here way
where are we going